for centuries our families fought
together against their common enemy
despite their differences
despite their suspicions we need to do
the same if we're gonna survive
[Music]
the enemy is real it's always been real
Game of Thrones
hey everybody were almost there new Game
of Thrones international trailer let's
break it down I was expecting more
promos to drop before the season got
here but not something like this this is
actually from Greece so that's why it
has these subtitles but there is a new
round of the giveaway I'll explain at
the end of the video if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything because we're gonna be doing
episodes starting next week it's largely
some of the same ideas but with
different footage so you see Daenerys
entering Dragonstone down here at the
base walking through it looks like this
continuous shot of her walking straight
to the throne room you see a much more
well lit shot of her staring at
Stannis's banner and tearing it down
so not everything at Game of Thrones
look like it's filmed at the dead of
night that's one of the only complaints
that unless you watch it in the highest
quality possible-- there are some scenes
when they filmed it at night are around
firelight it is almost impossible to
make out what's going on so there are
actually a couple details in this
trailer that are much much clearer than
in the previous version of the trailer
that HBO dropped but you get that same
Jon Snow voiceover about the enemy being
real how they need to come together put
aside their ancient entities and you get
a much better look at the ring of Jon
Snow's party that are circled up here
looking like they're getting ready to be
overtaken by the White Walkers so
they've been a lot of theories about
Gendry showing up in that storyline a
lot of rumors but there's actually one
character here you see all these swords
sticking out around there's one
character that has a Warhammer so it
doesn't necessarily confirm Gendry you
can't make his face out but this is what
Robert's classic Warhammer looked like
that he used during Robert's rebellion
this looks exactly like the Warhammer
that this person is holding here so I
think that's the metaphor that they're
going for the son of Robert Baratheon
wielding the weapon of Robert Baratheon
although this could be newly forged is
always possible to the Gendry forged it
himself if it is him but episode 2 is
titled Stormborn that's mostly referring
to Daenerys because she's called
Daenerys Stormborn because she was born
during a storm at Dragonstone
but the ancestral home of the Baratheon
has been storms end so you could say
that Gendry is also storm born so that
could be a subtle wink to him people
just think that the episode titles tend
to favor Daenerys because it starts with
Dragonstone then Stormborn
then in Queens justice even though
that's a bit more ambiguous because it's
also talking about Queen Cersei but you
get a brand-new shot of Sansa in
Winterfell with her hood on then you see
Cersei walking into her big mapa room
they're still constructing it in all the
shots that we've seen so far like you
said little pieces of it is the person's
drawing it there's been some cool
behind-the-scenes of that it looks like
it's from the first or second episode
when she looks to take Westeros the
actress Lena Headey has said some really
funny things about her character too or
depending on how you look at it she
tends to laugh a lot about how terrible
Cersei is going to be this season like
she's going to be this awful awful
person to everyone around her including
Jaime she said that at least at the
beginning of the season
Jaime is hopelessly devoted to her in
Cersei treats him like an emotional
vampire would she's just using everyone
around her so episode three Queens
justice in the description it talked
about Jaime realizing mistakes that he's
made that makes a little more clear that
that's also referring to mistakes that
he's made with Cersei maybe believing in
her too much but I love the way they
mirrored this Cersei shot with Tyrion in
Daenerys his throne room in his eyes
sort of dart to the side like he's
really nervous
about somebody that just walked in maybe
this is a shot from when Jon Snow shows
up because there's another shot of
people entering but it still seems like
people from Daenerys his own camp like
this doesn't look like Jon Snow or
anybody from the north
you don't walk around in the dead of
winter like you're headed to the beach
but then you get a better shot of Jamie
at what looks like Highgarden it's just
hard to tell from the stonework and the
castle behind him here but Highgarden
just seems like one of the big victories
that the Lannisters are going to have
and it seems like they're rolling it in
full force here a slightly better shot
of Jon Snow drawing his sword in haste
looking like something is getting ready
to charge him down but then you see this
big white open shot here with his band
slowly marching in the background you
can see them really tiny and frame here
this doesn't look like the lands of
always winter but it does look like
they're much further north of the wall
than they've been before like somewhere
maybe in this open region here there's
that same shot of drogon riding over the
field but this looks a little more
linear because you see these Lannister
soldiers here bracing like something's
getting ready to charge them like the
Dothraki are getting ready to run them
down
while drogon is riding up here so I
didn't like the way they cut this
trailer a little bit better
you see Theon kneeling down on the beach
and then you see all these shots from
the north with the night cane the army
of the Dead in bran working all these
rabens with the night cane just turning
his head but you get much more drawn-out
versions of those shots that you've seen
in previous trailers so I love that the
night King just casually turns his head
and looks at the camera like he's
watching us watch him as if we're the
eyes of bran
you know like I said you know because
this is a much higher quality version of
the previous footage that we've seen you
can now tell a hundred percent that this
person standing next to bran and the
heart tree in the Winterfell godswood is
not Davos so it's just a maester that
was left over from when the Bolton's
controlled Winterfell from a last season
otherwise it's mostly just the same
footage there have been a couple more
interviews that have dropped I know
you're all very skeptical about some of
the things actors have been saying
especially about the conflict in the
north in the revolt most of that seems
like it's going to be wrapped up in the
first couple of episodes even though the
way the actors like sophie Turner and
Aidan Gillen make it sound like that's
going to be a much bigger conflict when
you think about previous seasons even
though their storyline seems very
significant it actually doesn't
encompass that much time and when you
think about all the big plot points that
we have to hit we have to hit army of
the Dead
Daenerys Alliance dealing with Cersei in
the south and then brand sort of getting
everybody on the same page as to what
the history of the White Walkers in the
night King are there's just not enough
time to deal with a lot of the minor
personal conflict that they've been
teasing the first couple of episodes so
what's gonna happen is is there'll be
more bonus videos next week if there's a
new promo I'll do a video for it the
first episode is gonna drop on Sunday so
if you're new to the channel typically
what I do is I'll do a bonus video
Sunday morning that I'll do my episode
videos Sunday night then I'll do trailer
videos and anything else that you guys
request but I am bringing Q&A is back I
used to do more of those but people tend
to like them for the bigger shows so
Game of Thrones Q&A czar here but if
there any specific videos you guys want
before the season starts just leave them
in the comments below but in addition to
Game of Thrones starting there's a bunch
of Comic Con stuff that'll all be
separate so I'll do videos explaining
what's going on with that throughout the
week but the weekly giveaways for the
HBO now subscription so the latest
giveaway winner Antonio Denison please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there'll be a new round the next
time I post a Game of Thrones video
while you wait for everything you can
click here for my breakdown of the first
three episode titles and descriptions
and you can click here for the other big
trailer promo videos thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight